a truck sprays chemicals to disinfect
the air around the galaxy hotel a
hundred and forty eight asylum seekers
and two staff members here have tested
positive for coronavirus most show no
symptoms which may be how the disease
escaped the authorities attention until
now but that may change
we saw one man taken to hospital with
breathing problems the outbreak has led
to concerns of infection among people
from the local community here in
southern Greece who supply or maintain
the hotel like this a couple we tested a
hundred and seventy seven people who
came into contact with refugees like
supermarket workers couriers bank
workers and pharmacists and were
tremendously relieved to find out today
that all these samples are negative
which means there's been no spread of
the infection there have been two
previous outbreaks in facilities housing
asylum seekers but infection rates there
reached 1% of the resident population or
less before authorities quarantined them
here for the first time they have
reached 31% it is exactly what
authorities have sought to prevent and
it is what they want to prevent
happening in the more crowded camps on
the Aegean islands home to 35,000 asylum
seekers here people live in cramped huts
and tents and there's limited access to
running water and soap fears of a corona
virus outbreak earlier this month caused
a riot at the refugee camp on here which
destroyed offices the International
Organization for Migration which runs 30
refugee camps on the mainland including
the galaxy hotel says information is
vital to prevent panic what is essential
is to make sure that the migrant
community understands what is going on
we try to identify community leaders
knowing that we will try to pass message
I convey messages they are important to
those leaders the same thing that we did
is to create a network of what's up so
to try to keep the reform because if
they are not in form you know they they
they don't understand and they
they make assumptions that that leading
to panic and interpro the Greek
government has put the entire region
under quarantine and it says it'll stop
using hotels to house migrants this year
but the Haley relies on tourism for
revenue and its leaders want to open up
for business as soon as possible jumps
are Apollo's Al Jazeera reporter Haley